what's going on guys this is Rob and I'm
packing everything up which is why it's
kind of that kind of the void of space
behind me that was our space but it's
just empty space but I want to talk
about Marvel legacy for a minute or two
you know I've had my little rant you
know jumped on periscope earlier and got
my irritation out of my system and all
that kind of good stuff now I think that
making a youtube video is a time to be
reasonable and kind of you know like hey
let's approach this from a logical
standpoint although I imagine a lot of
you are still pretty angry
and rightfully so um Marvel's in a weird
situation right now I mean first and
foremost for me Marvel legacy my words
my works going to cut out for me right
like they'll bring back a lot of classic
characters and they're combining them
with new characters a lot of people are
getting into comics for the very first
time while the legacy will be there
jumping on point and they won't really
know a whole lot about the classic
characters they might be curious about
them or ever the case may be but it'll
offer me the opportunity to go through
and I guess begin the process of
bringing back character explanations
bringing back like team explanations
which I've been needing to do for quite
some time honestly I love the idea of
telling stories talking about stories in
my channel but after a while you just
kind of get burned out of doing stories
all the time and you just want to try
something different kind of go back to I
guess more original content but the fact
remains you know for me I feel like
Marvel legacies kind of been in it or
Marvel Comics has been in kind of a
tough spot recently a lot of people have
been getting irritated with Marvel
because I think the despite what
different writers or different fans may
may say I think most people read comic
books either out of curiosity just you
know for the sake of learning about
something new or because they like the
escape me I for example sometimes just
like to veg out and just read a story
about the Incredible Hulk
just wrecking stuff you know under play
three stories about the Incredible Hulk
just ripping things to pieces you know
like crushing vehicles and tear folks
apart you know sometimes I just like to
read stories about four you know just
smashing folks with us hammer or Captain
America just free Dom you know and
they're just fighting on behalf of the
awesome Avengers or something like that
I'm not really sure but I like to veg
out and just read those stories
I think that Marvel's tactic I guess of
being more topical at the moment you
know putting a lot of politics into
their stories I think it's sort of
driven people off and I think it's
created kind of an issue the reason why
I say that is you know let's take for
example like Captain America it's no
secret that a lot of people are really
irritated with what's going on in the
Captain America comics right now you
know for example like secret Empire a
lot of people don't like the idea of
secret Empire and I think the reason why
they feel that way coming from really
trying to understand the perspective
because I enjoy secret Empire I think
it's a good story but coming from their
perspective I think that for them
Captain America kind of represents like
the moral foundation of the Marvel
Universe he's the one guy that always
does the right thing he's the one guys
you can always count on he's the one guy
where despite not being nearly as
powerful as a lot of those superheroes
out there his word is basically along
when Captain America says hey look this
is what we're going to do then like the
argument stops and that's what gets done
just because of the fact that within the
Kalibak landscape a lot of superheroes
have a lot of respect for one and I
think a lot of people looking at that
and seeing that he's basically a bad guy
kind of takes away from what they
consider to be the moral fiber I guess
of the Marvel Universe I mean let's say
for example Superman you know Superman
is as well as Superman is he doesn't
leave the planet Earth to find people
who wouldn't know who Superman is and
even then there's no guarantee and
there's probably alien somewhere reading
the Superman comic I have no idea I'd
like to believe that's true I think it'd
be pretty amazing go to Mars and find
Martians reading like you know Action
Comics number one I think it'd be kind
of funny but um an effect remains the
Superman is the the moral backbone of DC
Comics he's waxed he's Wayne there's a
you know Golden Age Superman who you
know it'll in the eyes of a lot of
people never did anything wrong there's
the modern-day superman who's a little
more like neil morally ambiguous but
people look at superman and say he's the
moral backbone of the Justice League of
the DC Universe if you look at the
instances when Superman has been a bad
guy they're usually always alternate
reality stories for example like
injustice The Joker tricked Superman
into killing Lois Lane and his unborn
child Superman went crazy lost his mind
and instituted this you know
international
I guess domination of the world just
became like this fascist leader join my
the Sinestro Corps the yellow Lantern
Corps all that kind of stuff when you
look at Superman red Sun you know that
tells a story where he was adopted by a
Russian family because he landed in
Russia instead of landing in the United
States the results is that he's
eventually discovered and taken in by
Joseph Stalin and he's raised to become
a propaganda piece and eventually
becomes dictator of the world instilling
this perfect utopia basically do through
mind control but when he looked at these
different alternate reality versions of
Superman for the most part he's a bad
guy in those you never really see an
instance where he's like you know vying
for world domination in the main DC
Universe because he's like the one
character you just don't change the one
guy do you usually always keep the same
again he's died and different things
like that but for the most part he's
always a good guy and a lot of folks who
Captain America the same way um you know
for me that the political element for
example of Marvel Comics is something
that I've kind of struggled with I think
there are some stories that lend
themselves to political discussions or
tropical discussions more so than
anything else I think Captain America
Sam Wilson is a great opportunity to
focus on topical discussions I think
stories like Black Panther and the crew
are a great opportunity to focus on
topical discussions I don't think the
champions is a comic that should focus
on politics I don't really think the
Avengers is a comic district focus on
politics and Captain America to a degree
but only insofar as like how it affects
freedom or something along those lines
but I don't really think the comic books
across the board should focus on
politics and that's why I think stories
like Black Panther and the crew would
have succeeded and everything not been
focusing on politics and Marvel Comics
at the moment for me if I want to focus
on real world issues if I want to focus
on what our governments of the world are
doing or something like that you know
I'll turn on c-span or CNN or Fox News
MSNBC some news companies somewhere and
digest that for coming books I want to
read about a fictional character with
the fictional set of abilities that are
impossible to have in the real world
achieving impossible odds against an
overwhelming force that's what I want
that's what I enjoy I just like the
fighting I like the storytelling I like
the grandiosity of it all you know I'd
like the interpersonal relationships I
mean it's fine you know if they deal
with the political aspect x-men always
did that x-men always focus on the idea
of oppression but x-men didn't invoke
you know the actions of Bill Clinton for
the
part the x-men didn't invoke the IME all
the actions of george w our senior is
George HW Bush Cena MIT really invoke
that it was just the idea of people like
William Stryker
you know this religious fundamentalist
who believed it was a mission from God
to kill mutants there was always usually
confined to the comic books themselves
and the environment of the comic books
and I kind of feel like over time that
feeling has been forgotten I feel like
all the time that seems to have gone
away and what I'm hoping with Marvel
legacy is that comes back that we get
this you know return to familiarity we
still stay topical we still would you
know deal with the idea of mutants
focusing on oppression we still deal
with these issues that people can relate
to we just do it in a way that you know
political correctness isn't being thrown
at everybody you know that every comic
book is not a political statement on the
current state of the United States and
all the things that are wrong with it
again I know what's wrong with the
country I don't need that kind of books
to tell me that instead
you know I'm what the comic books to
help me escape that even if it's only
for an hour or two hours or something
along those lines so I mean at this
point it's really too early to tell when
it comes to tomorrow legacy I mean in
the end all we've really got into covers
they really haven't given us anything we
know that most of the titles that we
have are going to stay some of those
titles might change there's been you
know three or four publications that
have been introduced that are brand new
model two in one's coming back we're
still just going to be kind of fun the
Marvel two-in-one line of stories those
you guys who don't know work right they
were pretty fun there it was pretty cool
to just see team ups you know in a lot
of different adventures they usually
start Ben Grimm but they were pretty
cool back in the day Ben Grimm being
goofy and kind of weird of course we get
Bruce Banner the incredible non sorry we
get on Amadeus Cho he's going to stay as
The Incredible Hulk
the classic will rain comes back you
know there's some things that are for
the most part staying the same but it
looks like a lot of the classic
characters that we know are going to be
making the return responded be
incredible hope will probably come back
the she-hulk titles being rebranded just
a few things here and there that are
going to kind of be adjusted but what
I'm hoping for is that it's the stories
themselves that begin to see a shift
that it's the stories themselves that go
back to the idea of what made Marvel
great because I don't think politics is
what made Marvel great I think that was
a part of it but I think that what made
Marvel grade was the ears and the AHS
being Wow being enamored
by these fictional characters I could do
insane things Peter Parker empowering
teenagers Carol Danvers empowering young
women the Fantastic Four
exploring the depths of space in these
different realities The Incredible Hulk
just smashing stuff you know I think
those are the kind of things that that
drove people to fall in love with comics
in the first place and I'm really hoping
we get that return with Marvel legacy
but anyway guys just wanted to kind of
throw that out there you know give you
give you guys my that's better get it as
my own thoughts on you know where things
stand at the moment again I think it's
really too easy not too early to tell
but at this point I guess I'll be
rolling out character and team
explanations we have to have some of the
stories that I really enjoyed from
all-new all-different marvel immortal
2.0 and yeah so anyway guys we're to go
ahead and bring this video to an end and
we'll catch you all later please
[Music]